the double child killer colin pitchfork
has been arrested and recalled to prison
just two months after his release after
breaching conditions of his license
pitchfork was jailed for life in 1988
for raping and strangling to 15 year old
girls in leicestershire well our
correspondent aisha saheed is here in
the studio and aisha
just remind us a little bit of the
background to this case and why he's
been recalled to prison so quickly after
fighting for his release well it's not
quite clear what exactly happened he was
released on 40 license conditions
and he must have breached one or
potentially more of them to be recalled
this early
now if we look at what exactly happened
he was given a life sentence in 1988 for
raping and strangling two
fifteen-year-olds linda mann and dawn
ashworth in leicestershire in 1983 and
1986 respectively and following his
arrest in 1987 he was the first man to
be convicted for murder based on dna
evidence he received a life sentence
with a 30-year minimum term his minimum
term was reduced by two years in 2009
and despite two denied requests for
parole one in 2016 and the other in 2018
he was deemed suitable for release in
march this year he was let go with as i
said more around 40 license conditions
in september and today we've learned
he's been recalled back to prison most
likely for breaching one if not more of
these conditions now his release earlier
this year was a highly contentious one
that in june the justice secretary at
the time robert buckland asked for the
parole board to re-examine their
decision they rejected this government
challenge which mr buckland said he was
disappointed by but he respected their
decision
and the big question is what happens now
it's likely that pitchfork will spend a
substantial amount of time in prison
within 28 days the parole board will
have to make a decision a formal review
on what to do with him it's likely they
will call for a full hearing where they
decide whether he is kept in an open
prison in a closed prison or whether he
is released and if he is kept in prison
there won't be another option
opportunity for a parole review until
mid-2023
aisha thanks very much